the headless Houseman that's the focus
of tonight's angle if you're wondering
whether the Democrats are on the verge
of blowing what is traditionally a huge
opportunity to pick up seats in the
midterm election cycle well you may be
onto something
now normally the party in power loses
seats in the cycle following a
presidential election so Democrats
thought picking up dozens of House seats
was going to be pretty easy all they
needed to do was to run against Trump
nationalize the election and the House
Majority would be theirs but now they
must confront or try to distract from
Trump's stellar economic record now
during a difficult spot because they
have to convince voters to vote against
their own pocketbooks this fall that's a
tough climb but let's ask a few
fundamental questions here what's the
future of the Democrat Party and who's
gonna lead it Massachusetts Democrat
congressman Seth Moulton addressed the
question on MSNBC earlier today the
leader of the Democratic Party who is
the leader of the Democratic Party yeah
that's what we asked does my silence say
something this is the challenge that we
have right now I don't think that people
are looking at leader Pelosi with all
due respect to her and say you know here
is the future of our party pray tell why
not well so who is the future of the
Democratic Party he was honest there let
me think
California senator Kamala Harris if you
had to be stuck in an elevator with
either president Trump Mike Pence or
Jeff Sessions who would it be
does one of us have to come out alive
how about New York New Jersey senator
Cory Booker why is this so important why
is this so disturbing for me why am I
frankly seething with anger your silence
and your amnesia is complicity angry
what about Massachusetts senator
Elizabeth Warren
and my Aunt Bea has walked by that
picture at least a thousand times
remarked that he that her father my
papaw had high cheekbones like all of
the Indians do or Joe Biden yes I said
Amtrak Joe Biden who even now is touring
the country on a book tour
stand up shop doesn't see you Oh God
love you what am I talking about you
cannot go to a 7-eleven Dunkin Donuts
unless you have a slight Indian accent
no I wish we're in high school I could
take him behind the gym and punch him in
the mouth punch him in the mouth there
we could have just done the whole show
and Biden because we were in the car
early and I was screaming laughing with
Raymond okay it's just that if you're in
a bad mood watch Joe Biden on YouTube
and by the way they told us that Trump
uses violent rhetoric Oh
Fighting's always ready to punch someone
out well meanwhile billionaire Starbucks
founder Howard Schultz is also
reportedly mulling a move into politics
concerns me that so many voices within
the Democratic Party are going so far to
the left and I asked myself how are we
going to pay for all these things in
terms of things like single-payer our
people espousing the fact that what the
government is going to give everyone a
job and I think we've got to get away
from all of these falsehoods and start
talking about the truth and not false
promises okay but there's only one
problem for Democrats Trump has been
speaking truth and has been delivering
real promises as president now he's
connected with the Forgotten voters the
Democrats now seek and he's actually
made their lives better
Trump's Real Clear Politics approval
rating average is now at forty four
point six percent unemployment is at its
lowest level in 17 years and the RCP
Politics average on the direction of the
country that a country is going in is up
to nearly 40 percent up from 27% two
years ago under Obama
so all that's left for the Democrats to
prattle on about are got all these side
issues yeah there's cable news catnip
irrelevant to the lives of most people
do Americans really care about whether a
cabinet secretary bought a used mattress
at the Trump Hotel why did he do that by
the way or whether Jared Kushner got a
security clearance or the endless
speculation about the whereabouts of the
first lady after surgery well if you
like most people you care about
pocketbook issues your safety and your
culture and decline all around you and
your children all the things that Trump
is fearlessly addressing and winning on
so the left gripes and moans about the
only things the left they have left of
them which is basically the small stuff
it's meant to distract the president and
lure him on to their turf I'm telling
you it is not working they're gonna new
need a new game plan if they're going to
get to the two big things that the
Democrats lack a leader and an agenda
and that's the angle